Now let's apply derivatives to physics --
Newton's Second Law of Motion.
We're looking at one-dimensional motion.
Think of the train we saw before.
Some force is exerted on object of mass m.
What does happen? The velocity of this object changes.
And Newton's Second Law describes that relationship.
The mass times the acceleration is that force.
If you keep the same object, the same mass
and double the force, we double the acceleration --
the change of velocity.
If we want to accelerate an object of twice the mass,
we need twice the force.
Mass is measured in kilograms internationally.
Acceleration is the rate of change of velocity -- v dot --
the derivative of the velocity with respect to time,
or as velocity is the derivative of position with respect to time,
the derivative of the derivative of the position with respect to time.
Velocity is meters per second internationally,
and the change would be meters per second --
per second by how many meters per second,
thus the velocity change per second --
that is m/s².
Force is given in kg times m/s²,
and there's a short name for that -- Newtons --
because obviously, Newton was the one to find this.